the engineers and artists who have
written about and developed the cool
technology we're seeing this evening
carry on a tradition built over
centuries when people think about
writing for movies they think about
screenplays but some of the most
important writing in the film industry
is in a technical research tonight we're
here to recognize some of that
groundbreaking work the ASC color
decision list is a framework developed
by the ASCS Technology Committee it
allows the interchange of RGB colour
correction information between equipment
and software may by made by more than 30
manufacturers and share between
different facilities it's a wonderfully
innovative tool that maintains the color
look from onset through dailies
editorial all the way through post
visual effects and color correction for
the development of the American Society
of Cinematographers colored color
division list technology the Academy
presents josh pines david Reisner lu
Leveson curtis clark and david register
with a technical achievement award with
the technical achievement award
gentlemen
please please wrap up what a dump go and
yes these are really heavy uh it's an
honor to be here competing at this
year's annual Winter Olympics for geeks
we are [ __ ] riot in drag my name is
Joshua and I am a knocko no sorry rocks
beach right crowd just Rock speech I'd
like to thank the academy for giving us
only 45 seconds each to thank the
zillions who helped make the ASC color
decision list such an integral part of
filmmaking this is especially be good
because now we have a fabulous excuse
for not having to thank really anyone at
all sorry we have props no I don't need
that so here's a brief list of those I'd
like to thank but sorry dude no time a
punched paper tape was the method used
for describing color correction
information in the fabulous days of film
and cinematographers lamented no longer
having the similar mechanism a mechanism
to accurately and repeatedly described
their creative looks as things went
downhill I mean as things went digital
so we came together under the auspices
of the American Society of
Cinematographers created the CDL or
color decision list which allows DPS to
have their creative vision passed from
on set to dailies all the way through
the stages of post-production including
editorial visual effects and final
digital intermediate color correction
I'm trying to go really fast I'd like to
thank Satan oh no no the scientific and
technical awards nominating committee
for presenting us with this award I have
to thank all of these guys wives because
apparently that's something you have to
do they were all going to speak quickly
and finally my all my valentine's day
love goes to my darling daughter Sylvie
you had to put up with my dragging
around to all the screenings of classic
movies you got to raise them right he's
seeing you
I'm not even going to attempt to follow
that act I've known that for a long time
ever since we formed the AC technology
committee in 2003 so I just want to say
that I'd like to formally thank the
saitek Awards Committee for this very
esteemed honor we're very appreciative
that I also want to make special
reference to our asd technology
committee they're not all up here this
is only a small sampling but it was that
group in the diligent efforts they put
into this that enabled us to achieve the
success that we did with the aacc dl
it's a great group ethos and the ASD CDL
represents the best of what our asd
Technology Committee is all about we
also love collaborating with the Academy
as well because we do that over aces but
we're very proud of this and we thank
you very much and and I also want to
thank my beautiful wife Margie for her
patience and tolerance and support for
everything that I do which entails a lot
of other wacky hours so anyway thank you
very much
I will go with what Josh and Curtis said
I will just add I'd like to thank my
family and my friends for putting up
with 10 years of late evening meetings
hundreds of late nights missed and we're
very pleased with the results that we
got it's been the ASC CDL has been more
widely used than we ever anticipated
it's now part of the workflow of more
than eighty percent of future motion
pictures so that came out pretty well
thank you in addition to the AC and the
acad sci tech committee i want to thank
Randy glim and Michael chrisman who came
up with the necessity that became the
mother of my part of this invention and
I'd like to thank my wife Patty for
being the source of all the best parts
of my life I would like to thank the
academy and the people involved in the
ASC Technology Committee it's impossible
to follow jobs so I've learned it not to
try but the two people that I would
really like to thank actually of all the
people behind us as I need to thank Alan
Davey oase and Stephen borromeo see
because they were the ones who put me on
the path of endless volunteering thank
you